This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedandu. There's an old saying attributed to Benjamin Franklin. Nothing is certain in life except for death and taxes. But death and taxes are not the only guarantees. If we live long enough, all of us will experience great setbacks, crises that seem insurmountable, challenges that seem far bigger than we are. When we see others go through natural disasters or terrible illnesses or the emotional upheavals that come from child custody battles or losing a livelihood, we think, how terrible for them.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本杰明·富兰克林曾有一句名言：人生中唯一确定的事就是死亡和纳税。但死亡和纳税并不是唯一的必然。如果我们活得足够久，我们所有人都会经历重大的挫折，经历看似无法逾越的危机，经历看似远超我们承受能力的挑战。当我们看到别人遭遇自然灾害、可怕的疾病，或是因争夺子女抚养权或失去生计而陷入情感动荡时，我们会想：他们太不幸了。
I'm so glad this didn't happen to me. But what we fail to see in these moments is that all of us are going to experience our own versions of these emergencies and tragedies. Having to deal with crises is an occupational hazard of being alive. What do we do in such moments? How do our minds respond when faced with catastrophe? And can we better prepare ourselves for their inevitable arrival? Today on the show, and in a companion piece on Hidden Brain+, we examine the psychology of battling a crisis.
我很庆幸这种事没发生在我身上。但我们在这些时刻未能意识到的是，我们每个人都会经历属于自己的紧急情况和悲剧。应对危机是活着的一种职业风险。在这样的时刻我们该怎么办？当面对灾难时，我们的头脑会如何反应？我们能否为这些不可避免的危机做好更好的准备？在今天的节目中，以及《Hidden Brain+》的配套内容里，我们将探讨应对危机的心理学。
It's part of our series Wellness 2.0. What happens in our minds when we face danger, and what we can learn from those who prove steadfast in such moments. Techniques and strategies for responding better when life throws us crises, curveballs, and catastrophes. This week on Hidden Brain. We are all called upon from time to time to do hard and sometimes seemingly impossible things. Do we rise to the occasion or do we fall short?
这是我们“健康2.0”系列的一部分。当我们面对危险时，我们的头脑会发生什么？我们能从那些在危机时刻表现坚定的人身上学到什么？当生活向我们抛出危机、变数和灾难时，有哪些技巧和策略可以让我们更好地应对？本周的《Hidden Brain》。我们每个人时不时都会被要求去做一些困难的，有时甚至是看似不可能的事情。我们是迎难而上，还是半途而废？
At Columbia University, psychologist Adam Galinsky has studied the science of decision making and leadership. What it takes to rise to the occasion and what happens in our minds when we don't. Adam Golinski, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. Adam, in January 2012, an Italian cruise ship carrying over 3,000 passengers and 1,000 crew members was on a seven-day voyage in the Mediterranean
在哥伦比亚大学，心理学家亚当·加林斯基研究了决策和领导力的科学。研究内容包括如何迎难而上，以及当我们做不到时，我们的头脑会发生什么。亚当·加林斯基，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢。亚当，2012年1月，一艘载有3000多名乘客和1000名船员的意大利游轮正在地中海进行为期七天的航行。
when it began to veer close to shore. It was unclear why this was happening, but eventually the ship, which was named the Costa Concordia, hit a reef. Mediterranean when it began to veer close to shore. It was unclear why this was happening, but eventually the ship, which was named the Costa Concordia, hit a reef. How deep was the reef and what happened to the ship, Adam? It was almost 30 feet below the surface, so the captain Francesco Ciotino couldn't see it, but it just tore a gigantic hole in the bottom of the ship, basically rendering the ship inoperable. I'm assuming that water must have flooded the generators and engines.
当时它开始偏离航线，靠近海岸。目前尚不清楚原因，但最终这艘名为“歌诗达协和号”的游轮撞上了一处暗礁。地中海当时它开始偏离航线，靠近海岸。目前尚不清楚原因，但最终这艘名为“歌诗达协和号”的游轮撞上了一处暗礁。那处暗礁有多深？船发生了什么事，亚当？它在水面下近30英尺处，所以船长弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺看不见它，但它在船底撕开了一个巨大的洞，基本上使船失去了航行能力。我猜水一定淹没了发电机和引擎。
The ship must have come to a standstill almost right away. Absolutely. It had a complete loss of power. There was a blackout that was involved. And basically, at that moment in time, this was essentially a shipwreck. So that's terrifying, Adam. But I'm guessing that when something like this happens, it's the job of the captain to take immediate action and begin rescuing passengers.
船一定几乎立刻就停了下来。绝对是这样。它完全断电了。当时发生了停电。基本上，在那一刻，这实际上就是一场海难。这太可怕了，亚当。但我猜当这种事情发生时，船长的职责是立即采取行动并开始营救乘客。
Did that happen? That's not what happened at all. In fact, he did not alert the authorities immediately. In fact, he spent a considerable amount of time trying to go into crisis management mode, figure out how he was going to protect his own reputation, and come up with a story that wouldn't place the responsibility on himself. He tried to come up with a story to say that rather than the sudden blackout, which was
他这么做了吗？事实完全不是这样。事实上，他没有立即通知当局。相反，他花了相当长的时间试图进入危机管理模式，想方设法保护自己的声誉，并编造一个不会让自己承担责任的故事。他试图编造一个说法，声称与其说是突然停电导致了
caused obviously by the accident and the water rushing in, was the actually the result of the accident rather than vice versa and his primary concern was how am I going to protect myself and he didn't spend any energy thinking about how he was going to protect the passengers. So when rescue efforts finally started almost an hour or maybe more than an hour after the ship first hit the reef, Did Captain Francesco Ciotino supervise and help passengers get off the ship? He did not. At the time that the Coast Guard was communicating with Ciotino about the rescue, he was already himself in a lifeboat and he
事故和涌入的海水，不如说是事故导致了停电，而他首要关心的是如何保护自己，他根本没有花任何精力去思考如何保护乘客。所以，当救援工作在船撞上暗礁近一小时甚至更久之后才开始时，弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺船长是否指挥并帮助乘客撤离了？他没有。当海岸警卫队与斯凯蒂诺沟通救援事宜时，他自己已经在救生艇上了，而且他
claimed that he did not intend to be in a lifeboat, that he fell and stumbled accidentally into the lifeboat. So while everyone else was on board and panicking, Captain Ciotino was safely in a lifeboat off of the ship. So let me just try and catch up with what's happening here. The ship has hit this reef. There's a gigantic hole in the ship. Water is flooding in. The passengers are fearing for their life. And the captain, instead of staying on board and helping the passengers, has himself gotten off the ship onto a lifeboat, but claims he did so accidentally? Absolutely. That's exactly what he claimed. He said that he stumbled and fell and actually slipped into the lifeboat. And now once he's in
声称他并不打算上救生艇，是意外跌倒才掉进救生艇的。所以，当其他人都在船上惊慌失措时，斯凯蒂诺船长却安全地待在船外的救生艇上。让我理清一下这里发生的事情。船撞上了暗礁，船体破了一个大洞，海水涌入，乘客们担心自己的生命安全。而船长不仅没有留在船上帮助乘客，反而自己撤离到了救生艇上，却声称是意外？绝对是这样。这正是他所声称的。他说他绊倒了，实际上是滑进了救生艇。现在他既然已经在
the lifeboat, there's no real reason to get off the lifeboat because he can quote, organize the rescue from there. I understand that he had a conversation with a member of the Coast Guard while sitting in the lifeboat. How did that conversation unfold? Well, the Coast Guard was furious that he was in the lifeboat
救生艇上了，就没有理由离开救生艇了，因为他可以引用他的话，“从那里组织救援”。我听说他在救生艇上时与海岸警卫队的一名成员进行了对话。那次对话是怎么进行的？嗯，海岸警卫队对他待在救生艇上感到非常愤怒，
and they were demanding that he climb back up. And they gave him very specific orders. Climb back up. Tell me how many people are on board. Tell me how many women are on board. How many children are on board. Gave him very clear instructions and Ciotino kept giving sort of mumbled answers about why he couldn't possibly go back on board. And eventually just stopped responding to the Coast Guard member. And you could see, you could hear in the Coast Guard member's voice,
他们要求他爬回去。他们给了他非常具体的指令：爬回去。告诉我船上有多少人。告诉我船上有多少妇女。有多少儿童。给了他非常明确的指示，而斯凯蒂诺一直含糊其辞，解释为什么他不可能回到船上。最终，他干脆停止回应海岸警卫队成员。你可以看到，你可以从海岸警卫队成员的声音中听到，
his fury and infuriation just consuming him. And at one point he was so furious, as he should know that he yelled, I will get you for this. Go to the port, you f***er! I'm hungry, you f***er! What are you doing? Go to the port, you f***er! Is it true that Ciotino somehow in the middle of all of this catastrophe had managed to change out of his uniform and was wearing something different when he got into the lifeboat? That is actually true. So if you were in the lifeboat and you were there with
他的愤怒和狂怒正在吞噬他。有一次他太生气了，正如他所知，他大喊道：“我会让你为此付出代价的！滚回船上去，你这个混蛋！我饿了，你这个混蛋！你在干什么？滚回船上去，你这个混蛋！”斯凯蒂诺在灾难发生时，真的设法换下了制服，在进入救生艇时穿了别的衣服吗？这确实是真的。所以如果你当时在救生艇上，和
Ciotino, you would not know that he was the captain of the ship because somehow in the course of this panic state where everyone is running around trying to save their lives, he managed to change out of his captain's uniform into his civilian clothing before he of course stumbled and accidentally fell into the lifeboat. So the cruise ship hits a reef, it's wrecked, it starts to sink, the captain essentially abandons ship. What happens to the passengers on board that day, Adam?
斯凯蒂诺在一起，你根本不知道他是船长，因为在每个人都在四处奔逃试图保命的恐慌状态下，他竟然设法换下了船长制服，穿上了平民服装，然后当然，他“绊倒”并意外掉进了救生艇。所以游轮撞上暗礁，损毁并开始下沉，船长基本上弃船逃生了。那天船上的乘客发生了什么，亚当？
It was a disaster. I mean, 32 members of the passengers passed away, perished, lost their lives because of this. And when we look back at it, it's very clear that as soon as the damage was done, as soon as the coastal Concordia had hit this reef, if Francesco Ciotino had immediately called the Coast Guard, had immediately come clean, had immediately set up a process of rescue,
那是一场灾难。我的意思是，32名乘客因此丧生。当我们回顾这件事时，很明显，一旦损坏发生，一旦“歌诗达协和号”撞上暗礁，如果弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺立即呼叫海岸警卫队，立即坦白情况，立即启动救援程序，
it's very likely that every single passenger would have survived and with no injuries. The captain was brought to trial. He was asked why he steered his ship so close to shore in the first place. Captain Francesco Ciotino claims that he went closer to shore in order to salute mariners who were on the shore. The prosecutors, on the shore. The prosecutors on the
很可能每一位乘客都能幸存，且不会受伤。船长被送上了法庭。他被问及为什么一开始要把船开得离岸那么近。弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺船长声称他靠近海岸是为了向岸上的水手致敬。检察官，在岸上。检察官在
hand claim that he had a more nefarious motive or a more lascivious motive which is his mistress, a dancer, was also on board and they suggest he was trying to impress her with his captainship. Was Francesco Ciotino held to account after the tragedy? He was. So, you know, I mentioned the Coast Guard said, you know, I will make you pay for this. And he was made to pay for it. He was sentenced to 16 years in prison for a variety of different counts, including abandoning his ship, but also manslaughter.
另一方面声称他有更邪恶或更淫秽的动机，那就是他的情妇，一名舞者，当时也在船上，他们认为他是想在情妇面前炫耀他的船长风采。弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺在悲剧发生后被追究责任了吗？是的。所以，我提到海岸警卫队说，“我会让你为此付出代价的”。他确实付出了代价。他因多项罪名被判处16年监禁，包括弃船罪，以及过失杀人罪。
But I think what's most interesting about the court case is that at no point would he take any responsibility. And he said, essentially, it's not my responsibility what happened. The story of Captain Francesco Ciotino is an unsettling one. Not only because of the tragedy that resulted from one man's poor judgment, cowardice, and selfishness, but also because of the uncomfortable questions it raises. Would you have responded differently in this scenario? After the ship started to sink, would you have done the brave thing? All of us would like to believe that we would act courageously in the face of danger.
但我认为此案最有趣的一点是，他始终没有承担任何责任。他基本上说，发生的事情不是我的责任。弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺船长的故事令人不安。不仅是因为一个人的错误判断、懦弱和自私导致的悲剧，还因为他引发了令人不安的问题。在这种情况下，你会做出不同的反应吗？船开始下沉后，你会做出勇敢的行为吗？我们所有人都愿意相信，面对危险时我们会表现得勇敢。
But in reality, we also know we are human. We too are prone to cowardice and selfishness. When we come back, why we crack in times of crisis and what we can learn from those who rise to the occasion. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2012, a cruise ship carrying thousands of passengers sank off the western coast of Italy claiming the lives of 32 people on board. It wasn't just a tragedy, but a preventable tragedy.
但实际上，我们也知道我们是人类。我们也容易产生懦弱和自私。回来后，我们将探讨为什么我们在危机时刻会崩溃，以及我们能从那些迎难而上的人身上学到什么。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2012年，一艘载有数千名乘客的游轮在意大利西海岸沉没，夺去了船上32人的生命。这不仅是一场悲剧，而且是一场可以预防的悲剧。
Captain Francesco Ciotino had no business steering the ship over a shallow reef, and his delay and inaction after the disaster cost many lives. Psychologist Adam Galinsky studies the science of leadership. He says the world is full of infuriating leaders like Francesco Ciotino, but there are also great ones. These inspiring leaders, as he calls them, can teach us a lot about how to endure in times of crisis.
弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺船长根本不该把船开过浅礁，他在灾难发生后的拖延和不作为导致了许多人的死亡。心理学家亚当·加林斯基研究领导力科学。他说，世界上充满了像弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺这样令人愤怒的领导者，但也有伟大的领导者。正如他所说，这些鼓舞人心的领导者可以教会我们很多关于如何在危机时刻坚持下去的道理。
Adam, let's talk a moment about some of the things that Francesco Ciotino did wrong that day. Yes, he should not have steered his ship so close to shore, but can you lay out some of the psychological mistakes he made after the ship hit the reef? I mean I think the first thing he was you know focused on the wrong details right so he was focused on the story that he could tell about how this event happened why there was this electrical blackout etc in order to in some ways save his own reputation he missed the larger picture, the bigger picture, which was now this boat was flooding water,
亚当，让我们谈谈弗朗切斯科·斯凯蒂诺那天做错的一些事情。是的，他不应该把船开得离岸那么近，但你能列举一下他在船撞上暗礁后犯下的一些心理错误吗？我的意思是，我认为他首先关注的是错误的细节，对吧？他关注的是他能编造出的关于这件事是如何发生的、为什么会停电等等的故事，以便在某种程度上挽救他自己的声誉。他忽略了更大的图景，即这艘船正在进水，
eventually it was gonna capsize, and that was gonna lead to potentially passengers loss of life, which it did. And if he had immediately understood, okay, the boat's been injured, it doesn't matter how it got injured at this point, the only thing that matters is how do we get everyone off board as quickly as possible?
最终会倾覆，这可能会导致乘客丧生，事实也确实如此。如果他能立即意识到，“好吧，船受损了，此时它是如何受损的并不重要，唯一重要的是我们如何尽快让所有人撤离”，
And so he, I mean, the first mistake he made, right, was he was focused on the wrong thing. But besides not taking responsibility for what happened, I understand he even tried to pass the buck. Absolutely, yeah. I mean, he tried to blame it on the helmsman, for example, and blame other people. And so it was a classic example of deny responsibility,
所以他，我的意思是，他犯的第一个错误是，他关注的是错误的事情。但除了不为发生的事情负责外，我听说他甚至试图推卸责任。绝对是这样。我的意思是，他试图把责任推给舵手，等等，去责怪其他人。所以这是一个典型的“否认责任”的例子，
it's not my fault. But the basic fundamental error he made was he was in a leadership role. He was a protector and steward of a group of people, but he was only focused on himself and what he could do to protect himself. And in doing so, he essentially abandoned his duty as a leader, right? And he was no longer a leader, but a single, selfish actor
“这不是我的错”。但他犯下的根本性错误是，他处于领导地位。他是一群人的保护者和管家，但他只关注自己以及他能做些什么来保护自己。这样做，他基本上放弃了作为领导者的职责，对吧？他不再是一个领导者，而是一个自私的个体，
working tirelessly on behalf of himself. Adam, let's take a look at a very different kind of leadership. In June 2018, 12 teenage boys on a soccer team in Thailand were on a hike with their coach. The coach was a 25 year old man named Ekapol Chanta Wong, commonly called Coach Ek. The team was exploring a cave and at one point they decided to turn back but what they didn't know was that weather conditions outside the cave had changed dramatically. Can you paint me a picture of what happened, Adam?
不知疲倦地为自己工作。亚当，让我们看看一种截然不同的领导力。2018年6月，泰国一支足球队的12名少年在教练的带领下徒步旅行。教练是一名25岁的男子，名叫埃卡波·钱塔翁，通常被称为“埃克教练”。球队正在探索一个洞穴，在某个时刻他们决定折返，但他们不知道的是，洞穴外的天气状况发生了剧烈变化。亚当，你能为我描绘一下当时发生了什么吗？
Yeah, they had been exploring this cave. They had walked about an hour into the cave. And what's remarkable about the story is when they went in, the sky was sunny. They had no thought that a storm might be brewing or they had to worry about that. It was the beginning of monsoon season or some might say monsoon season came early and a sudden and torrential downpour came down that was so extreme that it just flooded the cave. And so when they turned back they had probably been
是的，他们一直在探索这个洞穴。他们走进洞穴大约一个小时。这个故事最引人注目的是，当他们进去时，天空是晴朗的。他们根本没想到可能会有风暴酝酿，或者需要担心这个问题。那是季风季节的开始，或者有人可能会说季风季节提前到了，一场突如其来的倾盆大雨降下，雨势极大，直接淹没了洞穴。所以当他们折返时，他们可能已经
walking a little distance back when all sudden they got to a certain juncture where they were supposed to essentially go right and right was now filled with water, just completely filled with water. And so what Coach Eck did right then is he said, okay, we're going to try to find a way out. And so he decided to dive in, he tied a rope around his waist and he told the members of the soccer team, you know, when I pull on the rope, pull me back out. But after about two minutes, he hadn't pulled on the rope and they were panicking. So they pulled
往回走了一段距离，突然他们到达了一个特定的路口，他们本应该向右转，而右边现在已经充满了水，完全被水填满了。所以埃克教练当时做的就是他说：“好吧，我们要设法找到出路。”于是他决定潜入水中，他在腰间系了一根绳子，并告诉足球队的成员：“当我拉绳子时，把我拉回来。”但大约两分钟后，他没有拉绳子，他们惊慌失措。所以他们把
him back out and it's a good thing they did because he'd gotten a little stuck, a little disoriented. He had not found a way out. He was starting to struggle and they essentially saved his life. So as even more water surged into the cave, the boys were forced to go deeper into the cave to get shelter. Were they able to find it, Adam? At this point, the water had filled up kind of up to this juncture, so they kind of went in deeper. They knew they weren't going to be getting out anytime in the next few minutes,
他拉了回来，幸好他们这么做了，因为他被困住了一点，有点迷失方向。他没有找到出路。他开始挣扎，他们基本上救了他的命。随着更多的水涌入洞穴，男孩们被迫深入洞穴以寻求庇护。亚当，他们找到了吗？此时，水已经淹到了这个路口，所以他们就往更深处走去。他们知道在接下来的几分钟内是不可能出去了，
and they decided to, we're going to be spending the night here. They lie down, they got together for warmth and they slept through the night and they woke up and the first thing they noticed is that the water was creeping on them. They thought they'd gone deep enough, but they hadn't. There's even more water coming into the cave. I'm assuming they must have then retreated even deeper into the cave now as they tried
于是他们决定：“我们今晚要在这里过夜。”他们躺下，聚在一起取暖，睡了一夜。他们醒来后，首先注意到的是水正在向他们蔓延。他们以为自己走得够深了，但并没有。有更多的水涌入洞穴。我猜他们一定随后撤退到了洞穴更深处，试图
to escape the water. They did. They, you know, at various points, they kept retreating deeper and deeper into the cave. And then at some point, they heard a sound. And they actually thought it was a helicopter. And they thought they were about to be saved. And they turned around and that sound wasn't a helicopter, but it was almost like a tidal wave coming towards them.
逃离洪水。他们确实这样做了。他们在不同的点不断向洞穴更深处撤退。然后在某个时刻，他们听到了一种声音。他们实际上以为那是直升机。他们以为自己快要获救了。他们转过身，那声音不是直升机，而几乎像是一股潮汐向他们涌来。
The water was now surging. It wasn't just creeping on them. It was about to surround them and consume them. And they went as deep into the cave as they could, essentially in some ways to the highest point they could within the cave, almost on a ledge if you will, and now they were surrounded by water on all sides. And this was about day five and now they were stuck with essentially nowhere to go. So, this is completely terrifying, Adam. I can only imagine how scared the boys must have been.
水现在正在汹涌而来。它不仅仅是在蔓延。它即将包围并吞噬他们。他们尽可能深入洞穴，在某种程度上到达了洞穴内最高的地方，几乎是在一个壁架上，现在他们四面环水。这大约是第五天，现在他们被困住了，基本上无处可去。这太可怕了，亚当。我只能想象男孩们当时有多害怕。
What did Coach Eck have the boys do as they were perched on this ledge? Yeah, I mean, I think, you know, there's a couple of things that I think are really important to know about what Coach coach did in this situation. And the first and most important thing he did is that he. Convinced them that he had a plan to get them out. And the plan was we're going to dig our way out. We're going to go up through the roof and we're going to keep digging. And eventually we're going to dig all the way to safety.
当男孩们栖息在这个壁架上时，埃克教练让他们做了什么？是的，我的意思是，我认为在埃克教练在这种情况下所做的事情中，有几点我认为非常重要。他做的第一件也是最重要的事情是，他让他们相信他有一个带他们出去的计划。计划是：“我们要挖出一条出路。我们要穿过洞顶，我们要继续挖掘。最终我们要一直挖到安全的地方。”
And that's what they did from morning to night. They dug in shifts. Coach Eck dug harder than anyone else to the point his hands were bleeding. And they would ask him questions like, you know, how much longer? And he would say, just a little longer. And they all believed that they were working together to find this way out. I understand that to lift their mood, he would have them sing together to actually feel like they were a team doing something together?
这就是他们从早到晚所做的事情。他们轮流挖掘。埃克教练比任何人都挖得更卖力，以至于他的手都在流血。他们会问他诸如“还要多久？”之类的问题，他会说：“再坚持一会儿。”他们都相信他们正在共同努力寻找出路。我听说为了提振士气，他会让他们一起唱歌，让他们真正感觉自己是一个正在共同做某事的团队？
Yeah, absolutely. You know, and he understood that. And one of the reasons why he gave them this task of digging, I think he gave it for two reasons. One is to fill the day, right? To give them something to focus on so their minds wouldn't fracture
是的，绝对是这样。你知道，他明白这一点。我认为他给他们布置挖掘任务的原因之一，我想他有两个原因。一是填补时间，对吧？给他们一些专注的事情，这样他们的头脑就不会
under the pressure and the panic. But also to give them a to focus on so their minds wouldn't fracture under the pressure and the panic, but also to give them a sense of working together as a team. They were a team. They were a soccer team. So they knew how to work together. And so he created a sense of camaraderie, the sense of working together. And that prevented two things from happening, right? Like mental breakdown, prevented two things from happening, right? Like mental breakdown, but also interpersonal breakdown. It really prevented conflicts of emerging within the team because they're working together as a team. He had the boy set an alarm for six o'clock every morning. And I'm wondering why he did this day and night must have made no difference in the darkness of
在压力和恐慌下崩溃。但也是为了给他们一种团队合作的感觉。他们是一个团队。他们是一支足球队。所以他们知道如何合作。因此，他创造了一种友情，一种共同努力的感觉。这防止了两件事的发生，对吧？比如精神崩溃，但也防止了人际关系的崩溃。这确实防止了团队内部冲突的出现，因为他们作为一个团队在共同努力。他让男孩们每天早上六点定闹钟。我想知道他为什么要这样做，在洞穴的黑暗中，白天和黑夜一定没有什么区别。
the cave. And I'm wondering why he did this. Day and night must have made no difference in the darkness of the cave. Yeah, I mean, I think it's something it's something that he instinctively knew and understood that we all need structure for our days. This is something that NASA astronauts have known for a long time that when you're in space, they have them on an incredibly strict schedule. And so he understood like we're going to have a structure to the day. We're going to get up at six every day.
我想知道他为什么要这样做。在洞穴的黑暗中，白天和黑夜一定没有什么区别。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是他本能地知道和理解的事情，我们需要为我们的日子建立结构。这是美国国家航空航天局（NASA）的宇航员长期以来所知道的事情，当你在太空中时，他们会让他们遵循极其严格的时间表。所以他明白，“我们要为这一天建立一个结构。我们每天六点起床。”
We're going to dig, you know, until we're, you know, exhausted. And then we're going to sleep and then we're going to get up and we're going to dig again. Now there's something really important to remember is they went into this cave with no food. They didn't have a single morsel of food on them when they went in. They went in this cave with no water. They didn't have a single morsel of food on them when they went in. They went in this cave with no water. They didn't have any water. Now, they did actually end up having some water. And that's also something really remarkable about Coach Eck is that he understood they couldn't
“我们要挖掘，直到我们精疲力竭。然后我们要睡觉，然后我们要起床，我们要再次挖掘。”现在有一件非常重要的事情要记住，他们进入这个洞穴时没有食物。他们进去时身上连一点食物都没有。他们进入这个洞穴时没有水。他们进去时身上连一点食物都没有。他们进入这个洞穴时没有水。他们没有任何水。现在，他们实际上确实得到了一些水。这也是埃克教练非常了不起的一点，他明白他们不能
drink the muddy water that was surging around them. But there was water dripping through the roof. And he understood that because it was going through the mountain stones it was essentially being cleaned and so they were able to get water and give them that little bit of at least that type of nourishment that they needed. I understand that he had some of the stronger members of the team look out for weaker members of the team so he was paying attention to people who might have needed a little extra help. Absolutely he was in some ways an
喝周围涌动的浑水。但有水从洞顶滴下来。他明白，因为它穿过了山石，所以它基本上被净化了，所以他们能够得到水，并给他们提供至少那种他们所需要的营养。我听说他让队里一些强壮的成员照顾较弱的成员，所以他注意到了那些可能需要额外帮助的人。绝对是，他在某种程度上是一位
incredible mentor understanding the individual needs the the smallest member of the group he constantly encouraged him saying I know you can do it you're strong I believe in you he would sing sing with them, right, to help lift their mood. But he would also meditate with them to help keep them calm. And I think the meditation is particularly interesting one for for two reasons. First, at some point in this time, the oxygen levels in the cave were getting dangerously low. In fact, they fell probably below life-affirming levels at certain points and they still survived. And part of it was by doing this meditation,
了不起的导师，了解个人的需求。对于小组中最小的成员，他不断鼓励他，说：“我知道你能做到，你很强，我相信你。”他会和他们一起唱歌，对吧，以帮助提振他们的情绪。但他也会和他们一起冥想，以帮助保持冷静。我认为冥想特别有趣，原因有二。首先，在这一时期的某个时刻，洞穴中的氧气水平变得低得危险。事实上，在某些时候，它们可能降到了维持生命所需的水平以下，但他们仍然幸存了下来。部分原因是，通过进行这种冥想，
he was helping them conserve energy, but also use the oxygen more efficiently. So on the 10th day, the batteries of the boys' flashlights began to run out and Coach Eck told the boys to turn off the flashlights and be with one another in the dark. It was then that they heard something, Adam. What did they hear? They weren't sure but they thought they heard almost like a bubble come out of the water
他帮助他们节省了能量，也更有效地利用了氧气。所以到了第10天，男孩们手电筒的电池开始耗尽，埃克教练告诉男孩们关掉手电筒，在黑暗中陪伴彼此。就在那时，他们听到了什么，亚当？他们不确定，但他们认为他们听到了几乎像是水里冒出的气泡声，
and the word hello. And they were up on this ledge. The water had receded a little bit. And so they immediately kind of went down off the ledge towards where the water was. And they turned on their flashlights and there miraculously were two British divers who had spent 10 days trying to get in there. They'd been there alone without food, without water,
以及“你好”这个词。他们当时在壁架上。水已经退去了一点。所以他们立即从壁架上下来，朝着水所在的方向走去。他们打开了手电筒，奇迹般地出现了两名英国潜水员，他们花了10天时间试图进入那里。他们已经在那里待了10天，没有食物，没有水，
without a way to call for help, without warmth, for 10 days, and they had been miraculously found. So when the divers found the boys, they had been searching for them for over a week and everyone had been expecting the worst. The parents of the boys were already grieving. But Adam, you say the divers were shocked when they saw the boys' demeanor. How so? Well, the divers say they were horrified at how they looked.
没有办法呼救，没有温暖，他们奇迹般地被发现了。所以当潜水员找到男孩们时，他们已经搜寻了他们一个多星期，每个人都预料到了最坏的情况。男孩们的父母已经在悲伤了。但亚当，你说潜水员看到男孩们的举止时感到震惊。怎么会这样？嗯，潜水员说他们对他们的样子感到震惊。
They looked so emaciated. You could see the effect of 10 days of no food combined with all the effort they'd put into digging. But they were even more amazed by the demeanor of the soccer players. There wasn't a single trembling lip, right? They smiled, they seemed happy to see them, and they just were shocked that here was a
他们看起来非常消瘦。你可以看到10天没有食物加上他们投入挖掘的所有努力所产生的影响。但他们对足球运动员的举止感到更加惊讶。没有一个颤抖的嘴唇，对吧？他们微笑了，他们似乎很高兴见到他们，他们只是感到震惊，因为这里有一
group of people who suffered in some ways the most horrific deprivation possible, but that deprivation did not show on their facial expressions. So an army of people soon begins to extract the boys from the cave and divers are relaying messages from each team member to their parents. What did Coach Eck tell the parents to make sure the parents were doing okay as well during this time? He reassured them that the boys were going to be okay, that they were okay, that he was looking out for them.
群人，他们在某种程度上遭受了可能的最可怕的匮乏，但这种匮乏并没有表现在他们的面部表情上。所以一大群人很快开始将男孩们从洞穴中救出，潜水员们正在转达每个队员给他们父母的信息。埃克教练告诉父母们什么，以确保父母们在这段时间里也过得好？他向他们保证男孩们会没事的，他们很好，他在照顾他们，他们会没事的，你们很快就会见到他们，我很抱歉你们经历了这一切。所以这是一个了不起的故事，亚当，当然，如果风暴再严重一点，也许他们无法爬到安全地带，这个故事很容易以悲剧告终。所以很多因素都可能使这变成一场彻底的灾难。但你说埃克教练在那段时间里做了几件正确的事情，帮助了局势，我想让你带我了解一下他做出的一些选择，以及
He also apologized for what happened. But he basically said, I'm with the boys, I'm taking care of them, they're going to be okay, you're going to see them soon, I'm very sorry for what you've gone through. So this is a remarkable story, Adam, and of course the story could easily have ended in tragedy if the storm were a little worse, maybe they weren't able to climb to safety. So lots of factors could have turned this into a complete disaster. But you say there are several things that Coach Egg did right during that time that helped the situation, and I want you to walk me through some of the choices he made and
我们可以从中学习到什么。首先，你说他在与男孩们交谈时非常小心他所使用的词汇。怎么会这样？是的，我的意思是，我认为他明白他所说的一切都会产生巨大的影响，对吧，对男孩们。所以他非常非常小心，
what we can learn from them. First of all, you say he was very careful about the words he used as he was talking to the boys. How so? Yeah, I mean, I think he understood that everything that he said was gonna have a huge impact, right, on the boys. And so he was very, very careful
在许多不同的方面。首先，他从不使用“被困”这样的词，对吧？他从不使用“卡住”这样的词，对吧？他从不强调他们处于危险状态。他总是，他做的另一件事是，他明白他的力量就是他们的力量。有时他会感到不知所措，他需要哭泣。他需要释放那些情绪，但他明白，在他们睡觉时私下里这样做是非常关键的，因为他们知道如果他们看到他哭，这会击垮他们，他们会失去所有的希望。所以他明白他必须保持专注。他明白他们需要一个共同的目标，
in a number of different ways. First, he never used words like trapped, right? He never used words like stuck, right? He never, he never emphasized that they were in a perilous state. He always, another thing that he did is that he understood that his strength was their strength. And sometimes he got overwhelmed and he needed to cry. He needed to let those emotions, but he understood that it was really critical for him to do that privately where they couldn't see it when they were sleeping, for example, because they knew if they saw him cry, it would break them and they would sort of lose sort of essentially all hope. So he understood that he had to focus. He understood that they needed a shared goal
并且他们真的相信他们正在朝着一个真正的可能性努力。所以他说：“我们要挖出一条出路，我们要朝着那个目标努力。”他们会问：“还要多久？”他会说：“再坚持一会儿，对吧？”总是，“我们正在取得进展，我们快到了。”他做的另一件事是，他帮助他们编造了一个关于挖掘的另一边有什么的完整故事。
and that they really truly believed that they were working towards a real possibility. So he said, we're gonna dig our way out and we're gonna work towards that. And they would say, how much longer? He would say, just a little longer, right? It was always, we're making progress, we're getting there. Another thing he did was that he helped them craft a whole story about what was on the
所以他创造了一个关于橙子田的故事，他们会走出来，那里会有橙子，他们可以直接吃。他们在那片橙子田的尽头有一个小商店，他们会进去，他们会尽可能多地吃喝。然后他们会回去，他们会骑上自行车回家，就好像过去10天里没有人找他们一样。所以这三件事，比如对语言非常小心，对吧？从不谈论被困或卡住，对表达情绪非常小心，这样他表现出了冷静、力量、乐观和希望。
other side of their digging. So he created a story about an orange field that they would come out and there would be oranges right there that they could eat. And they had that at the end of the orange field, there is a little store and they would go in and they would get as much food and drink as they could possibly do. And then they would go back and they would get their bikes and they would ride home as if no one was looking them for the last 10 days. And so these three things like very careful with his language, right? Never talking about being trapped or stucked, very careful about what he expressed emotionally so that he portrayed calmness and strength and optimism and hope.
然后不仅给了他们挖掘出路的共同目标，还给了他们这个共同目标将导致什么，即他们正在努力前往的洞穴另一边的极乐世界。这个共同目标将导致什么。即他们正在努力前往的洞穴另一边的极乐世界。所以你做了一些研究，看看希望如何在危机时刻成为一种强大的动力。
And then even not only giving them shared goal of digging their way out, but giving them what that shared goal was gonna lead to, the Elysian Fields and the other side of the cave that they were working towards. what that shared goal was gonna lead to. The Elysian Fields and the other side of the cave that they were working towards. So you've done some research looking at how hope can be a powerful motivator in times of crisis.
你和伦敦商学院的托马斯·穆斯韦勒做了一些工作。告诉我这项研究以及你的发现，亚当。是的，我们发现，例如，在谈判中，我们可以考虑我们在谈判中试图避免或防止什么，或者我们可以考虑什么是他们的希望，他们在谈判中的理想结果。
You did some work with Thomas Muswiler of the London Business School. Tell me about this research and what you found, Adam. Yeah, we've found, for example, that in negotiations, we can think about what we're trying to avoid or prevent in the negotiation, or we can think about what is their hope, their ideal outcome is in the negotiation.
如果你让他们真正专注于此，这对他们处理谈判的方式会产生这种变革性的影响。他们变得更加乐观。他们变得更加自信，但以一种积极的方式，而不是一种攻击性的方式。他们变得更加坚持。正因为如此，他们最终获得了更好的结果。所以，埃克教练也帮助男孩们专注于一个共同的目标。所以，与其被动地等待被营救，他告诉男孩们他们必须挖出一条出路。现在，这可能确实是不可能做到的。
If you get them really focused on that, it has this transformative effect on how they approach the negotiation. They become more optimistic. They become more assertive, but in a positive way, not in a sort of aggressive way. And they become more persistent. And because of that, they end up getting better outcomes. So, Kocheck also helped the boys focus on a shared goal. So, rather than passively wait to be rescued, he told the boys that they had to dig their way out. Now, it well may have been impossible to do this.
我们实际上不知道他们必须挖多少，或者他们必须挖多远才能穿过洞顶进入这个，你知道，这个橙子田的天堂。但有一个共同的任务要做，并且感觉他们在一起，这本身在心理上就非常有帮助。绝对是这样。我会说一件事，他们挖掘实际上是不可能的，因为一旦他们被发现，我们知道了他们的确切位置，最初的营救想法之一是在洞穴上钻一个洞，但岩石太厚了，根本无法到达他们那里。所以他们的挖掘最终会遇到坚硬的岩石。但我们从一个世纪的研究中得知，
We actually don't know how much they would have had to dig or how far they would have had to dig to break through the roof into this, you know, this paradise of orange fields. But having a task to do in common and feeling like they were in it together, that in itself was psychologically very helpful. Absolutely. I will say one thing, it actually would have been impossible for them to dig because once they were discovered and we knew their exact location, one of the original ideas for getting them out was to drill a hole into the cave, but the rock was too thick and it was impossible to get to them. So their digging would eventually come up against shore rock. But we've known for a century of research
拥有一个共同的目标对于帮助任何群体保持在一起是不可思议的关键。共同目标对于减少冲突和帮助凝聚力至关重要。现在，你当然可以看到，埃克教练只是一个了不起的人。他碰巧是一个拥有这些超人能力的人。但在随后的采访中，他将自己的佛教僧侣训练归功于洞穴中发生的事情。告诉我一点关于那个训练的事情。
that having a shared goal is unbelievably critical for helping any group stay together. A shared goal is critical for reducing conflict and helping cohesion. Now, you can see, of course, that Coach Eck was just a remarkable human being. He happened to be someone with these superhuman capacities. But in interviews afterwards, he credits his own training as a Buddhist monk to what happened in the cave. Tell me a little bit about that training.
他童年时期发生了什么促使他接受僧侣训练？是的，埃克教练有一个非常悲惨的童年。他的兄弟去世了，他兄弟的离世彻底伤透了他母亲的心。然后她去世了，然后他的父亲也去世了，现在他成了孤儿。他被送到了一个佛教寺院。去世了，现在他成了孤儿。他被送到了一个佛教寺院。在这个佛教寺院里，他被训练成为一名佛教徒。九年来，他每天只吃一顿饭。
What happened during his own childhood that prompted him to get trained as a monk? Yeah, he had a very tragic childhood, Coach Eck. His brother passed away and his brother's loss literally broke the heart of his mom. And then she passed away, and then his dad passed away, and now he's an orphan. He was sent to a Buddhist monastery. passed away and now he's an orphan. He was sent to a Buddhist monastery. And in this Buddhist monastery, he was trained to be a Buddhist. And for nine years, he ate one meal a day.
这就是他所做的一切。这实际上成为了洞穴中一个关键的故事，因为他们会说：“我饿了。”他说：“我知道你饿了，但你的身体可以比你想象的坚持更久而不吃东西。”所以他可以从他自己的经历中讲述他自己的故事，比如：“我曾在很少食物的情况下幸存下来，我知道你们可以在很少食物的情况下幸存下来。”现在，作为一名佛教徒也教会了
That's all he did. And that became actually a critical story in the cave because they would be like, I'm hungry. And he says, I know you're hungry, but your body can go much longer than you think it can without food. And so he could tell his own story from his own experience of like, I've survived with little food, I know that you can survive with little food. Now, it also being a Buddhist taught
他冥想的艺术，保持冷静的艺术，接受我们所处境遇的艺术。我最近学到一个短语，我非常非常喜欢，那就是“我们无法控制风，但我们可以控制如何使用我们的帆”。我认为埃克教练就是一个很好的例子。这非常佛教，对吧？就像我们无法控制周围的世界，但我们可以控制我们对世界的反应，以及我们在面临的限制内如何运作。现在当然我们所有人不是僧侣，我们所有人也没有练习过九年
him the art of meditation, the art of remaining calm, the art of accepting the situations where we find ourselves. There's a phrase that I learned recently, which I really, really like is we can't control the wind, but we can control how we use our sails. And I think Kojic is a great example of that. It's a very Buddhist thing, right? Like we can't control the world around us, but we can control our reaction to the world and how we function within the constraints that we face. Now of course all of us are not monks and all of us have not had practice for nine years
每天只吃一顿饭，但这并不是故事的重点。重点是当我们经历充满挑战的时期时，我们都可以从过去的经历中汲取力量，试图度过我们正在经历的事情。谈谈你和乔里斯·拉默斯进行的一项研究。你让志愿者申请一份工作面试，来到实验室，然后做一个热身任务。亚当，这个热身任务是什么？是的，我们让他们思考一个他们拥有权力、控制局势的时刻，我们让他们反思拥有那种权力、处于控制地位是什么感觉。
going with one meal a day, but that's not really the point of us have not had practice for nine years going with one meal a day, but that's not really the point of the story. The point is when we're going through challenging times, we can all draw from our past experiences to try and get through what we're going through. Talk about a study that you conducted with Joris Lammers. You had volunteers apply for a job interview, come into the lab, and then do a warm-up task. What was this warm-up task, Adam? Yeah, we asked them to think about a time when they had power, when they were in control of a situation, and we had them to reflect on what it was like to have that power to be in control.
所以在那之后，我们告诉他们他们实际上要写一份求职申请。我们给了他们一个真实存在的招聘广告。我们说：“为这份工作写一封求职信。”每个人都做了。我应该告诉你，我们有两组学生，或者我应该说，在这项特定研究中有两组参与者，一半的人被要求思考一个他们处于控制地位、拥有权力的时刻。但另一半人被要求思考一个他们没有控制权、没有权力、是一个低权力的人、依赖他人的时刻。所以我们能够做的是，通过操纵或改变他们是专注于一个他们处于控制地位还是不处于控制地位的时刻，我们可以看到反思那种积极的类型
And so after that, we told them they were actually going to write an application for a job. We gave them a real job ad that existed. And we said, write, you know, a cover letter for this job. And everyone did that. And I should tell you that we had two groups of students, or two groups of participants, I should say, in this particular study, half the people were asked to think about time when they were in control, when they had power. But the other half were asked to think about a time when they weren't in control, when they didn't have power, they were a low-power person, they were dependent on others. And so what we're able to do is by manipulating or varying whether they focused on a time when they were in control or not in control, we could see how reflecting on that positive type
在那之后，我们告诉他们实际上要写一份求职申请。我们给他们提供了一份真实存在的招聘广告，并要求他们为这份工作写一封求职信。每个人都照做了。我应该说明的是，在这项特定的研究中，我们有两组学生，或者说两组参与者。一半的人被要求回想他们处于掌控地位、拥有权力的时刻；而另一半人则被要求回想他们无法掌控、没有权力、处于从属地位的时刻。因此，通过操纵或改变他们关注的是处于掌控还是无法掌控的时刻，我们能够观察到反思这种积极类型的影响。
of experience would affect how they did in their job applications. So it's not just in some ways drawing from your experience that can make you more prepared. It's almost recalling those moments that actually give you the motivation we need to do difficult things. Absolutely, and you know, what's interesting about this study is every single person in the study moments that actually give you the motivation we need to do difficult things. Absolutely.
的经验会如何影响他们在求职中的表现。所以，在某种程度上，不仅仅是借鉴你的经验能让你准备得更充分。这几乎是在回想那些时刻，它们确实给了我们做困难事情所需的动力。当然，你知道，这项研究有趣的地方在于，研究中的每个人……那些确实给了我们做困难事情所需动力的时刻。当然。
And you know, what's interesting about the study is every single person in the study had moments in their life when they had power and when they didn't have power. And so it's easy for them to reflect on those experiences with that. And because it's extraordinarily effective at changing people's psychological orientations. So what is it about recalling a time when we were powerful or recalling a time when we felt powerless? Why does that change what we do in the present, Adam? Yeah, I think what it does is it really puts us in this psychological mindset where we
你知道，这项研究有趣的地方在于，研究中的每个人在生活中都有过拥有权力和没有权力的时刻。因此，他们很容易反思这些经历。而且因为它在改变人们的心理取向方面非常有效。那么，回想我们拥有权力的时候或回想我们感到无力的时候，到底有什么意义呢？为什么这会改变我们在当下的行为，亚当？是的，我认为它真正做的是让我们进入这种心理状态，让我们
just look at the world in a different way. We at the world in a different way. We approach the world in a different way. In the study with Joris, what we did is we did so many different analyses of these different job applications and try to understand how they differed. They didn't differ in a ton of different dimensions. They didn't differ in how positive or negative they were, for example. But the one thing they differed in is that people could really feel a higher level of sort of confidence or self-efficacy that was coming from the people
只是以一种不同的方式看待世界。我们以不同的方式看待世界。我们以不同的方式对待世界。在与乔里斯的研究中，我们对这些不同的求职申请做了很多不同的分析，试图了解它们有何不同。它们在很多不同的维度上并没有什么不同。例如，它们在积极或消极程度上并没有什么不同。但它们唯一不同的地方在于，人们确实能感受到一种更高水平的自信或自我效能感，这种感觉来自于那些
that thought about a time when they had power. And one of the things that we've shown in our research over and over again is that recalling those experiences of being in control of having power really does make people more optimistic, right? And we already talked about how important optimism was for Coach Eck in that example. We've shown in our research that it makes people feel more connected to their true self, makes them feel more authentic. And we've actually shown in research, not ourselves, but some colleagues in Europe did some research where they told people they're going to now be videotaped and have to give
思考过自己拥有权力时刻的人。我们在研究中反复证明的一点是，回想那些掌控权力、拥有权力的经历确实会让人们变得更乐观，对吧？我们已经讨论过乐观对那个例子中的埃克教练有多重要。我们在研究中表明，它让人们感到与真实的自我更紧密相连，让他们感到更真实。我们实际上在研究中证明了——不是我们自己，而是我们在欧洲的一些同事做了一些研究——他们告诉人们现在要被录像并进行
a speech, which is an incredibly stressful experience for people. And why they did this, they actually had them hooked up to electrical connectors to measure their physiological responses. And what they showed is that simply recalling a time when you had power, when you're in control, made people feel more in control, right? And their physiological arousal literally went down. Most of us will never be faced with a terrifying challenge of rescuing a group of children
演讲，这对人们来说是一次极其紧张的经历。他们之所以这样做，是因为他们让人连接上电子连接器来测量他们的生理反应。他们所展示的是，仅仅回想你拥有权力、掌控局面的时刻，就会让人感到更有掌控力，对吧？他们的生理唤醒水平确实下降了。我们大多数人永远不会面临从洞穴中营救一群孩子的可怕挑战
from a cave. But in our own lives, we all encounter challenges, sometimes big, sometimes small. A sense of hope and purpose can motivate us to keep going when times get tough, and recalling prior times when we were brave can help us to act more courageously. When we come back, what happens when we are called to address a crisis and we have only seconds to act? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's easy to believe that courageous leaders are born courageous. They seem to embody the natural traits of heroism. In a crisis, they are cool, calm, and collected. Adam Gielinski is the author
。但在我们自己的生活中，我们都会遇到挑战，有时大，有时小。希望和目标感可以激励我们在困难时期继续前进，回想我们曾经勇敢的时刻可以帮助我们表现得更勇敢。回来后，当我们被要求应对危机且只有几秒钟时间采取行动时，会发生什么？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。人们很容易相信勇敢的领导者天生就是勇敢的。他们似乎体现了英雄主义的天生特质。在危机中，他们冷静、沉着、镇定。亚当·加林斯基是《激励：领导自己和他人的通用路径》的作者
of Inspire, The Universal Path for Leading Yourself and Others. He says that influential leaders have skills that can be learned and improved with practice. Adam, I want to talk about a woman named Tammy Jo Schulz. She was a pilot for Southwest Airlines and in April 2018, she was flying a plane from New York to Dallas when suddenly she felt an enormous jolt. How did Tammy Jo Schulz describe what happened that day? Well, she described it that she honestly thought that she'd had a mid-air collision. She felt like a Mack truck or another plane had just driven right into her. And she immediately knew after she felt this jolt that something was wrong because all
。他说，有影响力的领导者拥有可以通过练习学习和提高的技能。亚当，我想谈谈一位名叫塔米·乔·舒尔茨的女士。她是西南航空的一名飞行员，2018年4月，她正驾驶一架从纽约飞往达拉斯的飞机，突然感到一阵巨大的震动。塔米·乔·舒尔茨是如何描述那天发生的事情的？嗯，她描述说，她当时真的以为发生了空中相撞。她感觉就像一辆重型卡车或其他飞机直接撞向了她。在感觉到这次震动后，她立刻知道出了问题，因为所有
of a sudden the cabin pressure was going thing. She realized they were losing oxygen very quickly. And she realized immediately this was going to be unlike any other flight she'd ever taken. What exactly had happened, Adam? What had happened to the plane? So what happened was their left engine had experienced catastrophic failure. It essentially exploded. And when it exploded, not only did they lose that engine, it's a double engine plane.
突然间，机舱压力正在消失。她意识到他们正在非常迅速地失去氧气。她立刻意识到这将与她曾经执行过的任何其他飞行都不同。到底发生了什么，亚当？飞机发生了什么事？所以发生的事情是他们的左引擎发生了灾难性的故障。它基本上爆炸了。当它爆炸时，他们不仅失去了那个引擎——这是一架双引擎飞机。
They could have flown with the other engine, but the explosion tore a hole in the side of the plane. Wow, so the debris had smashed through the cabin. I'm imagining it must have been chaos back in the cabin. It was absolute chaos. So first of all, very tragically, one of the passengers who was sitting next to that hole was sucked into that hole. She didn't get sucked all the way out, but her injuries were fatal. Everyone began to panic. People were frantically trying to get on Wi-Fi to write to their family and friends, saying, I may never see you again, I love you.
他们本可以用另一个引擎飞行，但爆炸在机身侧面撕开了一个洞。哇，所以碎片撞穿了机舱。我能想象机舱里当时一定是一片混乱。那是绝对的混乱。首先，非常悲惨的是，坐在那个洞旁边的一名乘客被吸进了那个洞里。她没有被完全吸出去，但她的伤势是致命的。每个人都开始恐慌。人们疯狂地试图连接Wi-Fi写信给家人和朋友，说，我可能再也见不到你了，我爱你。
The flight attendants were panicking. You know, all of this was, it was just, yeah, pure chaos. So from the passengers perspective in the cabin, the plane is free-falling, total chaos, people thought they were going to die, but I want to play you a clip of the conversation between Tammy Jo Schulz and an air traffic controller. I understand your emergency let me know when you want to go in. Yeah we have a part of the aircraft missing so we're going to need to slow down a bit. Okay and are you as your airplane physically on fire? No it's not on fire but part of it's missing.
空乘人员也在恐慌。你知道，所有这一切，这简直就是，是的，纯粹的混乱。所以从机舱内乘客的角度来看，飞机正在自由落体，一片混乱，人们以为他们要死了，但我想播放一段塔米·乔·舒尔茨与空中交通管制员之间的对话片段。我了解你的紧急情况，当你准备好降落时告诉我。是的，我们的飞机有一部分缺失，所以我们需要减速一点。好的，你的飞机物理上着火了吗？不，它没有着火，但它的一部分缺失了。
So she seems remarkably calm Adam. Meanwhile back in the cabin people are sending goodbye messages to their loved ones. Absolutely. One of the things that she realized immediately is they needed to descend, right? They need to descend for lots of different reasons. One is the plane wanted to descend, so they wanted to do what the plane wanted to do, but also, obviously, oxygen was a big issue and the air pressure that was happening. And so they were actually doing what looked like a very fast descent, but was actually a controlled descent. And at a certain point, I think she realized the panic of the passengers,
所以她看起来非常冷静，亚当。与此同时，在机舱里，人们正在给亲人发送告别信息。当然。她立刻意识到的一件事是他们需要下降，对吧？他们需要下降的原因有很多。一个是飞机想要下降，所以他们想做飞机想做的事，但显然，氧气是一个大问题，还有当时发生的气压变化。所以他们实际上是在进行看起来非常快速的下降，但实际上是一个受控的下降。在某个时刻，我想她意识到了乘客的恐慌，
how they might be interpreting that descent. And I think maybe the most remarkable thing that she did that entire day is she went on the loudspeaker and announced to everyone 10 words. People will talk about those 10 words as being the 10 most important words they heard in their life. And those 10 words were we are not going down, we're going to Philadelphia. And so that 10 words let them know that there was a plan, that the going down was not chaos, you know, it was not a precipitous fall, it was an orchestrated descent. And people have said, you know, those 10 words literally turn the plane from panic to possibility.
他们可能如何解读那种下降。我想也许她那天做的最了不起的事情就是她通过扩音器向大家宣布了10个字。人们会谈论那10个字，称其为他们一生中听到的最重要的10个字。那10个字是：我们不会坠毁，我们要去费城。所以那10个字让他们知道有一个计划，坠毁不是混乱，你知道，那不是急剧的坠落，而是一次精心安排的下降。人们说，你知道，那10个字确实让飞机从恐慌转向了可能性。
So as the plane heads to Philadelphia, Tammy Jo Shultz takes control of the plane. What happens as they're coming in to land, Adam? The plane is not doing what it's supposed to be doing. She turns the plane and it doesn't churn. And she's so beflummoxed by this, she actually says out loud, and you can hear it in the recorder, Heavenly Father. She's looking for guidance. And she finally decides to take a slightly risky move, I think, with the rudder, and it churns at the last minute, just in time.
所以当飞机飞往费城时，塔米·乔·舒尔茨接管了飞机的控制权。当他们准备降落时发生了什么，亚当？飞机没有按照它应该做的那样运行。她转动飞机，但它没有转弯。她对此感到非常困惑，她甚至大声说了出来，你可以在记录仪里听到，天父啊。她在寻求指引。她最终决定在方向舵上采取一个稍微冒险的动作，我想，它在最后一刻转弯了，就在及时的时候。
I understand that she comes into land, but even as she's landing, she has the presence of mind to park right next to the fire trucks that are on the tarmac? Yeah, every step that she did was remarkable. She lands, she gets it so that the fire trucks are on the left side where the exploded engine was in case there's a fire. She also does something else which is which is really amazing is she recognizes some of these passengers might just try to get out of the plane as fast as they can and so she actually turned the flaps of the wings down to give people a little bit of a slide if they were gonna try to do that and so she was she was taking their perspective
我明白她降落了，但即使在降落时，她也有心思把飞机停在停机坪上的消防车旁边？是的，她做的每一步都非常了不起。她降落了，她让消防车停在左侧，也就是爆炸引擎所在的一侧，以防发生火灾。她还做了另一件非常令人惊奇的事情，那就是她意识到一些乘客可能只是想尽快离开飞机，所以她实际上把机翼的襟翼放了下来，给那些想尝试那样做的人提供了一个小滑梯，所以她是在站在
of a panic passenger and what they might try to do as soon as the plane lands. Hmm. I understand that after they got on the ground she walked back into the cabin and actually tried to look each person in the eye. Yeah so you know this was not an uncommon thing for Tammy Jo that when they had delays she would often go back into the cabin talk to the passengers but this time she went row by row deliberately talking to each and every passenger, making sure they're okay. She came to a little girl and this little girl was like, you know, pretty freaked out.
恐慌乘客的角度，考虑他们一旦飞机降落可能会尝试做什么。嗯。我听说在他们着陆后，她走回机舱，实际上试图看着每个人的眼睛。是的，所以你知道，这对塔米·乔来说并不是一件不寻常的事情，当他们延误时，她经常会回到机舱与乘客交谈，但这一次她一排一排地走，特意与每一位乘客交谈，确保他们没事。她来到一个小女孩身边，这个小女孩看起来，你知道，非常惊慌。
And she said, you got to do something no one else has ever done before on any of my planes. And as her parents said, she made our daughter feel special. And what's so funny is Tammy Jo talks about her voyage down the cabin and she says that she actually was shocked afterwards that more people, more reporters, more people talked about that walked down the aisle and meeting and greeting each of the passengers to make sure they're okay, then talked about how she landed this crippled flight, you know, and it shows how, in some ways, how starved we are for leaders who are compassionate and really connect to the people that they're leading.
她说，你做了一件我飞机上从来没有人做过的事情。正如她父母所说，她让我们女儿感到特别。有趣的是，塔米·乔谈到她在机舱里的那次航行，她说她事后感到震惊，更多的人、更多的记者、更多的人谈论那次走过过道并会见和问候每一位乘客以确保他们没事，而不是谈论她是如何降落这架受损航班的，你知道，这表明，在某种程度上，我们是多么渴望那些富有同情心并真正与他们所领导的人建立联系的领导者。
We talked earlier about how Captain Francesco Ciotino panicked when his cruise ship was sinking. By contrast, Tammy Jo Schultz really kept her head during the crisis, Adam. Absolutely. I mean, and she was so incredible that when she was checked out by medical personnel afterwards, one of them asked her a question that totally confused her. He said, how did you get through security? And she's like, what are you talking about? He's like, how did you get through security? And she's like, what are you talking about? He's like, how did you get through security
我们之前谈到弗朗切斯科·乔蒂诺船长在游轮沉没时是如何恐慌的。相比之下，塔米·乔·舒尔茨在危机中确实保持了冷静，亚当。当然。我的意思是，她太不可思议了，以至于当她事后接受医务人员检查时，其中一个人问了她一个让她完全困惑的问题。他说，你是怎么通过安检的？她说，你在说什么？他说，你是怎么通过安检的？她说，你在说什么？他说，你是怎么通过安检的
with your nerves of steel? He says, I'm taking your vitals right now and you're completely calm. Like your blood pressure's fine, your arousal's fine, your heart rate is normal. Like, how is that possible? And we heard that in her voice, the calmness in her voice, which is what was needed at that moment in time.
带着你那钢铁般的神经？他说，我正在测量你的生命体征，你完全冷静。就像你的血压正常，你的唤醒水平正常，你的心率正常。这怎么可能？我们在她的声音中听到了这一点，她声音中的冷静，这正是那一刻所需要的。
You told me earlier in the story of Kocek that in some ways what leaders do is magnified. So when they are upset, it has an effect on the people who are watching and observing them. When they are cheerful and optimistic, that has an effect on the people who are watching and observing them. When they are cheerful and optimistic, that has an effect on the people who are observing them. Here, perhaps, you know, Tammy Jo Schulz is always calm and always collected, but as a leader here, I think it was the case that her calmness
你之前在科切克的故事中告诉我，在某种程度上，领导者所做的事情会被放大。所以当他们心烦意乱时，这对观察和注视他们的人有影响。当他们开朗乐观时，这对观察和注视他们的人有影响。当他们开朗乐观时，这对观察他们的人有影响。在这里，也许，你知道，塔米·乔·舒尔茨总是冷静沉着，但作为这里的领导者，我认为情况是她的冷静
and courage under pressure, those were, you know, traits or behaviors that became infectious. Yeah, absolutely. So in general, our psychological states are contagious to other people. But that gets, they become truly, the word that you just used, infectious when we're leaders. And I've coined a phrase I call the leader amplification effect. And the idea that when we're leaders, all of our words, gestures, interactions,
和压力下的勇气，那些是，你知道，变得具有传染性的特质或行为。是的，当然。所以总的来说，我们的心理状态对其他人是有传染性的。但当我们要成为领导者时，它们就变得真正地——你刚才用的那个词——具有传染性了。我创造了一个短语，我称之为领导者放大效应。这个想法是，当我们成为领导者时，我们所有的言语、手势、互动，
even our silences, right, become amplified and that leads to intensified reactions. And so what we do as a leader really, really matters so much. And there's a coda to the story about Tammy Jerr-Schultz that really takes into account this idea of like the behavior of leaders matter. They told her she could take as much time that she wanted off, right? And she could come back whenever she wanted to. And she was back flying a few weeks later. And she said she partially did it for herself to return to sort of normalcy, but she also did it for other people to show that she had confidence and faith in Southwest Airlines
甚至我们的沉默，对吧，都会被放大，这会导致更强烈的反应。所以我们作为领导者所做的事情真的非常非常重要。关于塔米·乔·舒尔茨的故事还有一个尾声，真正考虑到了领导者的行为很重要这个想法。他们告诉她，她可以随心所欲地休假，对吧？她想什么时候回来都可以。几周后她就回来飞行了。她说她部分是为了自己回归某种正常状态，但她也为了其他人，以表明她对西南航空有信心和信念，
and that she had confidence in flight and to not let any conspiracies start to emerge, essentially what she said. So she understood that her actions were going to have an impact on other people. She was a leader on that plane, but now because of her reaction, she was a leader more broadly in the world and she really understood her role, which is exactly what Captain Ciotino did not understand. So there's something very interesting here, Adam. When many of us think of power, we think of the iron fist,
并且她对飞行有信心，不让任何阴谋论开始出现，这基本上是她所说的。所以她明白她的行为会对其他人产生影响。她是那架飞机上的领导者，但现在因为她的反应，她在世界上更广泛地成为了一名领导者，她真正理解了自己的角色，这正是乔蒂诺船长没有理解的。所以这里有一件非常有趣的事情，亚当。当我们许多人想到权力时，我们会想到铁腕，
of lacking emotion, being stern, being authoritarian. But in all the examples of powerful leaders who were successful that we've talked about today, there also seems to be a common thread of warmth and kindness. Can you talk about that? It seems that almost impossible, but in a moment of crisis, they were not just being competent, but they were genuinely caring about what was happening to the people around them. Yeah. And I think one of the reasons why these leaders are so remarkable is because they combine two elements that often don't go together in the powerful. One element is this sort of like courageous,
缺乏情感，严厉，专制。但在我们今天谈到的所有成功的强大领导者的例子中，似乎也有一条温暖和善良的共同主线。你能谈谈那个吗？这似乎几乎是不可能的，但在危机时刻，他们不仅表现出能力，而且真正关心周围人身上发生的事情。是的。我认为这些领导者之所以如此非凡，原因之一是因为他们结合了两个在强者身上往往不在一起的要素。一个要素是这种像勇敢的、
agentic, self-assured, self-efficacious person, but the other is a person that looks out for others. It really elevates them into the realm of an inspiring leader. Adam calls leaders who have sharp elbows and confrontational styles wire mesh leaders. And he calls people like Tammy Jo Schultz and Coach Eck, Terry Clot leaders. The terms come from a series of experiments in the 1950s showing animals gravitate to objects
代理性的、自信的、自我效能感强的人，但另一个是关心他人的人。这确实将他们提升到了鼓舞人心的领导者的境界。亚当称那些手肘尖锐、对抗风格的领导者为铁丝网领导者。他称像塔米·乔·舒尔茨和埃克教练这样的人为毛巾布领导者。这些术语来自20世纪50年代的一系列实验，显示动物会被那些
that feel warm and inviting. As followers, he says, we can instantly tell when we are being led by a wire mesh leader or a terrycloth leader. Sometimes wire mesh leaders can be very effective when they're trying to get people to, you know, coordinate the behavior or to go towards a particular course of action. But most of us need some terry cloth guidance, right?
感觉温暖和诱人的物体所吸引。作为追随者，他说，我们可以立即分辨出我们是被铁丝网领导者还是毛巾布领导者所领导。有时铁丝网领导者在试图让人们，你知道，协调行为或朝着特定的行动方针前进时可能非常有效。但我们大多数人需要一些毛巾布式的指导，对吧？
And you think about a pilot, right? A pilot is someone who is has a task to do, which is to take passengers safely from point A to point B. But they're not just an aviator, right? They're also a protector of those people, and they need to take into account their psychological states and what they need in order to be in a better place at any moment in time. So Adam, after doing this work, do you feel like you are more of a Terry Cloth leader when it comes to your own life? A key theme, I think, of inspiring leaders
你想到一名飞行员，对吧？飞行员是一个有任务要做的人，那就是将乘客安全地从A点带到B点。但他们不仅仅是一名飞行员，对吧？他们也是这些人的保护者，他们需要考虑到他们的心理状态以及他们在任何时刻为了处于更好的状态所需要的东西。所以亚当，在做了这项工作之后，你觉得在自己的生活中你更像是一名毛巾布领导者吗？我认为，鼓舞人心的领导者的一个关键主题
is that they reflect on their experiences. And they think about the times when they did things well, and they try to build off those. But they also think about the times when they didn't do things as well, and they try to recover from those. I can tell you, just as one experience that I had is I had a father who was prone to vicious bursts of rage. Like, you'd spill milk and he just would, his whole body would tense up and he would explode.
是他们反思自己的经历。他们思考自己做得好的时候，并试图以此为基础。但他们也思考自己做得不够好的时候，并试图从中恢复。我可以告诉你，就我的一次经历而言，我有一位父亲，他容易产生恶毒的愤怒爆发。就像，你洒了牛奶，他就会，他的整个身体会紧绷，他会爆炸。
And early on when I was a parent with these two little kids, they would do something and it really felt like my dad had taken over my body and I would just explode and I could immediately see the reaction in my child. I mean, he would go into a state of crying that was like just an abject state of fear. And I trained myself over time to never have that reaction again. I probably had it a dozen times.
早些时候，当我作为两个小孩的父亲时，他们会做一些事情，这真的感觉像是我父亲接管了我的身体，我会直接爆炸，我可以立即看到我孩子脸上的反应。我的意思是，他会进入一种哭泣的状态，那就像是一种极度的恐惧状态。我随着时间的推移训练自己再也不要有那种反应。我可能经历过十几次。
And I would just, I mean, he would go into a fugue state of crying as if like he was in an altered state, like I had shocked his system so bad. And I realized I could never do that again. And so I've trained myself. The other day, my son was really upset that we were going out and I just sat there with them and I was like, I know it's so hard. I want to be with you too.
我的意思是，他会进入一种恍惚的哭泣状态，就好像他处于一种改变的状态，就像我严重震惊了他的系统一样。我意识到我再也不能那样做了。所以我训练了自己。前几天，我儿子因为我们要出去而非常难过，我就坐在他身边，我说，我知道这很难。我也想和你在一起。
And I love you so much. I didn't react to his anger, his tears, his frustration. I was able to be there. And every time I did it, it got easier And every time I did it, it got easier the next time I did it. I was creating a habit, a practice of being empathic in there. And that's the key theme, I think, of Inspire that I think that I most want people to take away,
我非常爱你。我没有对他的愤怒、泪水、沮丧做出反应。我能够陪伴在那里。每次我这样做，它就变得更容易，每次我这样做，它就变得更容易。下一次我这样做时。我正在养成一种习惯，一种在其中保持共情的练习。我认为这就是《激励》的关键主题，也是我最希望人们带走的东西，
which is that we can all learn to be more inspiring. We can all learn through reflection, through commitments, and through practice. Adam Galinsky is the author of Inspire, The Universal Path for Leading Yourself and Others. In my conversation with Adam, we discussed another powerful idea that is a core element of leadership in times of crisis.
那就是我们都可以学习变得更具激励性。我们都可以通过反思、承诺和练习来学习。亚当·加林斯基是《激励：领导自己和他人的通用路径》的作者。在我和亚当的谈话中，我们讨论了另一个强大的想法，它是危机时期领导力的核心要素。
Leading is not about doing everything yourself. It's about enabling others. In our companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we explore how one specific superpower can transform the art of leadership. That episode, titled The Power of Perspective, is available right now to subscribers of HiddenBrain Plus. This is a particularly good time to give our podcast subscription a try. We're extending our standard seven-day trial period for listeners on Apple podcasts. Sign up in January and you'll get 30 free days to try it out. You can sample HiddenBrain Plus by going to apple.co slash hidden brain and click try free. Again go to apple.co slash hidden brain and click try free.
领导不是关于自己做所有事情。而是关于赋能他人。在我们《隐藏的大脑Plus》的配套剧集中，我们探讨了一种特定的超能力如何改变领导艺术。那集名为《视角的权力》，现在可供《隐藏的大脑Plus》订阅者收听。这是一个尝试我们播客订阅的特别好时机。我们正在为Apple播客的听众延长标准的七天试用期。在一月份注册，你将获得30天的免费试用期。你可以通过访问apple.co/hiddenbrain并点击免费试用来体验《隐藏的大脑Plus》。再次访问apple.co/hiddenbrain并点击免费试用。
Adam Galinsky thank you so much for joining me today on HiddenBrain. Oh thank you so much. It was is plenty. Then email the file to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line leadership. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
亚当·加林斯基，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。哦，非常感谢。这很充足。然后将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“领导力”。再次重申，电子邮件地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week in our Wellness 2.0 series, how to figure out what you want from your life. We don't want to think that I chose the wrong thing. That creates dissonance, it's uncomfortable, and so we protect ourselves from that thought. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。下周在我们的“健康2.0”系列中，如何弄清楚你想要从生活中得到什么。我们不想认为我选择了错误的事情。这会产生认知失调，这很不舒服，所以我们保护自己免受那种想法的影响。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。